(energetic music)
- It's a lot of
garbage out there.
I'm not just talkin' about
McDonald's wrappers and dead
hamsters, I'm talkin' about
douche bags and dirt bags.
Lotta D's and bags behind 'em.
If you want one guy to come
after them it's not the police.
Danny,
or Griff,
or Doc.
We're the Defenders, okay?
(sleuthlike music)
Everything safe?
- No safe, but you
have permit to...
- We have permits,
rights, all that stuff.
- You are security obviously...
- Right, right.
Can I see your permits?
- Huh?
- Can I see your permits?
You have permits?
Can I talk to who's
ever on that line?
Feel safe today?
- Yeah.
- You safe in there?
- [Woman] Hello?
- Alright.
We're defending it.
- Well I'm glad
you're here then.
- You see the purple,
you feel safe.
- Okay.
- My definition of a Defender?
You live in peace until
it's time to not use peace.
'Til it's time to use these.
You know, not the gloves, my
hands underneath the gloves.
- [Security Guard]
How you doin'?
- [Griff] Security, right?
- [Security Guard] Yes.
- [Griff] Security as well.
Nice to meet you.
- [Security Guard] Yes.
- I just wanna make sure
you're doin' the proper things
to make this building secure.
- [Danny] That's right.
- You got on a jacket, you're
wearin' identification,
that is great.
But what I would say,
Sir, is you wanna
have correct posture.
Hands across,
a dead stare.
No smiles.
- What's his name?
- His name's Chef.
- Chef.
You see it?
- Nope.
I found this lighter though.
- That ain't good.
You see it yet?
My partners in there,
he's lookin' for a cat.
You haven't seen a cat have you?
- How's it goin'?
- [Griff] Cat?
Meow.
- Meow.
- Meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
Hello Kitty?
- Ahh.
- Hello Kitty.
(western music)
This is one bad dude.
- I don't like that guy.
(country music)
- What's happenin', Mama?
Alright.
Ladies, I'm right here.
I ain't goin' no where.
It's free.
You too, daddy, let's get goin'.
Get them shades on, brother.
Tooowee!
Aye!
Give me some toots!
(horn honking)
Now that is a damn shame.
Break dancin' catastrophe
if I ever seen one.
I need to eat.
Come on, one of you
get in my mouth.
Oh!
Haha!
- [Men] Ooowee!
(laughter)
- [The Rebel] Alright, guys!
- It's only three
of us right now.
We got a potential fourth in
Tucson, but he's gotta get
his stuff together and
pay for his jacket.
- Ooo, nobody.
Ooo, yeah I can see good.
- Anybody in there,
nothin' suspicious?
- No, nobody.
- It's secure?
- Yeah, very secure.
- Very good.
- The best part about bein'
a Defender is just to be able
to reach out to people.
You can feel the warmth.
And it's a beautiful feelin'
to have people connect with you
especially
being black and
walkin' up on somebody.
It kinda...
It can be pretty
risky sometimes.
- [Men In Green] Polska,
Polska, Polska, Polska.
- Danny, what's that?
- [Men In Green] Polska,
Polska, Polska, Polska, Polska.
Polska, Polska,
Polska, Polska, Polska!
Polska, Polska, Polska,
Polska, Polska, Polska, Polska.
Polska!
Polska, Polska,
Polska, Polska, Polska.
- Is everyone in here safe?
- [Men In Green]
Polska, Polska, Polska.
- [Danny] Who are those guys?
- It's a Polish light bulb team.
- They were quick.
- They do good work.
- We help dudes.
We dudes that help other dudes
and we're community dudes.
That's what we do as dudes.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Coulda taken out an ankle there.
People ask me what
a Defender is.
I'd rather tell you
what a Defender is not.
We're not cops, we're not
smokers, jokers or goofballs.
We are not robots, we
are not 47 years old.
We are not your
grandma's apple pie.
But we're certainly
not Canadians 'cause
streets need watchin'.
We're the Defenders.
(sleuthlike music)
- Greetings video watcher.
Go back and click on my
brother's feat of strength
for a special, extra special
video we couldn't
show you originally.